a new trailer for doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness so here i am i was
gonna do it when it came on the super
bowl and was like oh watch the whole
trailer online the whole trailer was
online but i won't lie i was kind of
invested during the super bowl i mean
not invested in the super bowl itself i
had no dog in that fight but invested in
the fact that all these celebrities
holding their breath for the entire
duration of a super bowl game that is
madness but now we have a trailer for
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness is actually the second trailer
for doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness the first one was the
post-credits scene for spider-man no way
home didn't do a video on that one don't
know why which means now i really got to
make up for it because this movie is one
of my anticipated movies of 2022 and
from this trailer i watched the trailer
i was like well that's why also when i'm
talking about this trailer spoilers for
spider-man no way home just in case you
weren't one of the
many many people who saw the movie this
trailer looks like madness indeed
multiverse of madness there's just a lot
of bat [ __ ] imagery going on in this
trailer ergo going on in this movie i
also love the music in this trailer it's
all eerie all right
you gotta love it i don't know i just
like that sound kind of funny doctor
strange talking to wanda which was
supposed to happen at the end of juan
division they were like no this is
wanda's show when you see it in this
trailer you're like
bobby you could have had that dialogue i
mean more has happened since so it does
work out i don't see what's wrong with
the two of them talking it just makes
sense that they talk she does bring up
an interesting point though she's like
when you break the rules you're a hero
when i break the rules i'm the enemy
that doesn't seem fair not sure if it's
a false equivalency i don't know the
logistics of the actual conversation
what she is comparing because a lot has
happened doctor strange can be like well
and all the things that i've done in my
time of being sorcerer supreme and then
not being sorcerer supreme apparently i
did not enslave a town and make them my
mindless husk vanity project puppets
against their well while they're all
crying tears like she's crazy she's
hurting like you know that didn't happen
i didn't do that so there is that or he
could just be like hiro have you seen
what people have been saying about me
online these dicks on youtube like this
jeremy john's [ __ ] have you seen saying
i'm an idiot for fracturing the
multiverse because the kid asked me
really really nicely because he wanted
his friends to go to the same college as
him
saying it out loud it does kind of seem
stupid to do that it'll be like peter
parker remember she'll be like who's
peter parker and he'll be like that's
right this conversation is kind of
pointless no no but you know probably a
very interesting conversation i'm
looking forward to in this movie i know
you want me to talk about the thing the
voiceover i will
hold your horse's internet i'm really
glad mordo's back cause chiwatel ejiofor
is a great actor mordove was interesting
we saw essentially the origin story of
him being mordo so
i was surprised he wasn't brought in
earlier and then yeah doctor strange is
among what looks like a council or a
court and then you hear a voice a voice
that sounds very familiar we should tell
him the truth which actually took me a
second it was like a delayed response
the response was kind of like jango
fett's seismic charges i had that delay
we should tell him the truth
oh is is that
and i will not lie to you i've been
trying to think of other people other
old guys that might sound like patrick
stewart
i can't think of him that really sounds
like patrick stewart which sounds like
oh professor x apparently is now in the
mcu possible you know they bought up fox
fox had the x-men the x-men coming to
the mcu is
it's not a matter of if it is definitely
when so it might very well be professor
xavier or it be in marvel studios it
could be patrick stewart playing a
different character i know would be a
dick move but it wouldn't be the first
time marvel studios cast someone to look
like they were a character crossover
turns out that that character was just
someone else if they really do have
their finger to the pulse of the online
chatter their ear to the ground they
would know they shouldn't do that yeah
that might very well be professor x i
mean also would have been pretty sweet
to save that for the movie that said
that that one line is in this trailer
and it is just one line and has people
speculating uh that does build some hype
who knows point is doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness i'm glad to
see sam raimi back to direct well i mean
he hasn't done an mcu movie before but
his history with horror and comic book
movies looks to be blending together to
making something that is truly strange
and madness so the new trailer for
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
oh
[Music]